[Music]
what's up you [ __ ] filthy [ __ ] if
if you guys want to hear us without the
video stuff guess what we also have this
in a podcast form if you want to know
how to get to those podcasts you could
check it in the links below and remember
if you're listening to it check it on
the app or whatever give us a five start
because we need those [ __ ] reviews in
homeschooled pilot news submitted by
love from the six two six a highly
regarded passenger pilot was exposed as
a fraud oh [ __ ] what the hell like catch
me if you can [ __ ] like he's pretending
to be a pilot what happened okay so
Russian media featured this story of
this highly regarded passenger pilot
Vladimir Putin I know his name is Todd
show slash nikka oh sure yeah mr.
Kalashnikov cars shots so he so they're
saying that he's a complete fraud
that apparently back in 2015 he was
co-piloting a passenger flight from
Moscow to Cyprus and then when he was
entering the Ukrainian airspace he
shouted I'm not I don't know what I'm
doing himself II had a conscious know
what he said was glory to Ukraine
that's what he said and so apparently
that was so unusual that there's no one
says glory to set it over the thing he's
like Gloria cry he was talking to ground
control o ye the big [ __ ] that got into
my head yeah picturing it
yeah and Sony the guy with the [ __ ]
glow sticks all right that's ground
control right he's like yeah they sit in
the tower Louis I'm pretty
behind the computer and my brother is
actually an air traffic controller yeah
and that's what they do they're in the
tower and they have the world sticks as
well you have to run out and do the
glowstick thing and then they go back in
the tower and have to talk it's weird in
every time I think of those guys I think
of Breaking Bad
oh my crappy toys yeah yeah anyway so
much pressure to be in that tower facing
so much pressure because if you [ __ ] up
things collide I know
there we go all right so anyway so he
said that and then so the his co-workers
thought that that was really strange
and so they ended up contacting Russia's
Federal Security Service KGB they're
calling it that does beers the former
KGB I mean the KGB is the former yeah
wait what which way is the one KGB came
first turned into the FSB they contacted
them and then that's when they did a
background check and it revealed that he
was never a real pilot that could for
him she was a flight enthusiast who
taught himself how to fly using flight
simulators that in video games video
games work man no one said video games
we don't know that's what a flight sim
is yo a video game yeah but I thought it
was the one that actually like makes you
you tried once again you try to pants me
once again your pants are all the way
down I know but I thought the actual
simulators like when you're moving in it
yeah yeah it's a video game
yeah you don't know what the hell are
you thinking in any video game or the
[ __ ] the NASCAR video game we play
yeah we're Steve kept [ __ ] crashing
into everyone that was wrecking your
[ __ ] the whole time the simulator yeah
there's different levels of video game
understand you thought that this way I
get it there's different levels to it
alright hey man nice try though
no she's not wrong okay wrong where's
the same way she's wrong it's it's a
video game
there's Nintendo 64 and then there's the
whole [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] it's all video
games alright I'm just trying to stick
up for the gamers out there cuz they can
take a lot of [ __ ] a lot of people
saying what's all this game and [ __ ] for
it improves your reflexes number one
hand-eye coordination and eye
coordination gets you more [ __ ] gets
you way more [ __ ] way more [ __ ]
nowadays sometimes you do diamond in a
Japanese internet internet cafe that all
regaining that happens that's true but
most importantly you can do [ __ ] like
this and actually pilot a [ __ ] plane
come on dude that's tight it's the
American dream I learned how to make
money on a video game you gonna do what
make money on a video game dress myself
and buy new cars call GTA oh dude the
best oh yeah the secret is to play a
girl and then everybody helps you yep
they gave you [ __ ] that's right for no
reason characters not just don't have a
microphone because that's you're a girl
and then you like Saints Row oh good you
running around in lingerie [ __ ]
running a gang and [ __ ] that's why I
remember like cuz my brother always used
to play his girl characters and then I
was always like why are you playing
drill heads of this [ __ ] lame right
but then I realized the whole time
you're looking at the girl from behind
you seen her ass running around the
whole time and she's just gone yep I'm
like I'm the one who's gay yep you want
to see a buff guy I'm glad he's looking
buff dudes the whole my whole life
playing yeah now I only play his chick
hair me too because the same reason I
was like why oh why do you have a girl
character aren't they weekers like no
the stats are the same that's the thing
there's jiggle all over yeah they're
just hotter better I can't like oh
that's like Tomb Raider
exactly womb Raider alright so back to
this guy so it turns out that he faked
his diploma that his friend's father had
a flying simulator he was a teacher Oh
so that's how they wanna do it that's my
that was my question I'm like how did he
get access to that he just got on the
plane you just like good luck everybody
will see the only pilot was he copilot
no he was a co-pilot too so or when he
did the glory to your crane thing he was
co-piloting it was like it's like doing
a group science project didn't like the
one guys doing all the work the other
guys like oh yeah sorry my [ __ ] life
yeah where everyone else is doing the
work but got you to the director yeah
we're all here baby oh yeah yep
shoutouts to Jenny hang for helping me
pass high school because I would always
join a group of my friends and all my
friends Souls like [ __ ] man just a bunch
of idiots yeah I just wanted to talk in
a circle and [ __ ] and I'm like well
who's gonna do the work what am i mean I
mean oh [ __ ] it alright whatever let's
go I was you know like let's go out of
school nobody was on board that thought
really I was like let's get out of here
we're like oh so you did the work he's
like no I quit school literally let me
sign myself out of high school
the minute the oh I asked my [ __ ]
administration's like what age can I
sign myself I think it was like 16 or 17
as soon as it was my [ __ ] birthday I
went and I said I'm signing myself out
of school whoo and I left I did not know
you could even I didn't know that you
[ __ ] up so hard if I knew you could do
that I would have done it a long time
oh my god I was like the whole school
year cuz your birthday's in April she
had two months left
No so I was still like I was not a
senior yet I was at year cuz I was held
back one year am I gonna stay mr.
Brigance better
he's like actually GL I was held back
one year so so why would I want to stay
another year in your face Chia all you
would have been a 5 year like me yeah I
was a 5 out of 5 in high school for 5
years so you know what I did I signed
myself out to [ __ ] start a [ __ ]
company do you do anything this was a
smarter move because I don't want to
spend an extra year so I just took the
GED and I graduated before everyone else
- why didn't you do that because my
friend cuz I have new friends now all
the jeers became seniors are my new
friends all that [ __ ] I have new
friends graduate with them mmm I
undergraduate are like 500 extra credits
because I [ __ ] lucky girl
you couldn't even transfer to your call
for the ceremony to be with your friends
no and then like I could I was even
allowed to go to the ceremony because I
got coffee like a senior prank pink well
I didn't get caught but like a bunch of
people did so everyone that was even
accused couldn't go so I didn't pull the
prank that's some Gustavo
ass [ __ ] yeah I just drew a dicks around
the school at the neon orange I did it
but they but then there wasn't your idea
for the prank is what you're saying I
didn't get caught for everyone else
accuse all the other like good kids they
ratted on each other me and my other
three other friends we never rat on each
other they trying to pull that [ __ ] a
good cop bad cop I already know yeah
they probably ratted on you that's why
oh and it no that's great yeah so none
of us none of everyone else got arrest
in this [ __ ] oh wow I love they still
got you though that's crazy they just
assumed they're just like you can't go
you can't go but I didn't arrest it and
I didn't you're fine but some of the
kids got finally $10,000 what the hell
of honey though were they pretty funny
dicks my dicks were really funny
yeah good ah this one other guy he liked
or trees down there [ __ ] so that was
pretty quick what the hell what how is
that funny
Oh Landscaping funny little man I [ __ ]
my [ __ ] was funny I've added kid trim
the bushes it's like hey I think your
prank kid were you talking about the
trash she starts like cleaning up the
school yeah I showed you [ __ ]
please about taking down the board
scraping off the [ __ ] gum from the
floor
oh yeah he vandalized the bathroom was
so yeah I guess that's a prank yes
senior prank you [ __ ] do landscape if
only you could teach these kids that
that would be a prank we'd have a
cleaner world we'd be cleaning in
Singapore dude I showed you [ __ ]
this guy trim the trees yes this whole
thing came out right that Russian media
reported all that and so this dude a
friend of his like they've contacted a
friend of his this friend said that he
was in Honduras called piloting for
another small airline but then they
ended up finding him in Ukraine and then
once they interviewed him he said that
the Russian media made all that stuff up
to get him fired the the fact that he's
a fake pilot you may not that all up so
he could be fired for saying glory to
Ukraine and so who knows what's true
here yeah if it's happening in [ __ ]
Russia I never know what the truth is
yeah there is no truth yeah it's always
the reverse the opposite that's the
whole Russia meme right but when I think
of Russia I go corruption that's what I
think do you not go rush it corruption
yep vodka and corruption that's what I
think I do not like vodka vodka
scratching and you don't like vodka
vodka straight up I can't I can't I
don't know straight up meeting like out
of a shot guys like yeah I feel like
vodka it was just this is too tied to
getting drunk and throwing up you can't
do no tequila she really is an American
whiskey I like tequila it tastes good no
yeah because I got wearables not too
cute what a tequila and mess call or
[ __ ] bum let me tell you Don Julio
Blanco is tequila
that's [ __ ] the best tequila I've
ever had that's my deal what is it oh
yeah oh oh really that's your dad
Sergio's name look I have to use and ts2
now okay oh yeah you do yes I do yes I
do some Tina's right
[Music]